time is 6 42 keeping women safe with
just a click of a button local Cosmetics
company SOS Cosmetics launched this
lipstick last year it hides test strips
that can detect if your drink has been
tampered with this month is Sexual
Assault Awareness Month and tonight
there's going to be a block party in the
arts district to raise awareness Candice
Charles joins us live from the entrance
of the block party with the impact this
Nevada company is making it's huge and
it's awesome good morning Candace it
really is huge and awesome Heather you
got it completely right good morning to
you good morning folks this is the Smart
safety lipstick now the founder is
trying to change the world one lipstick
at a time and this block party is going
to help I'll have the SOS founder with
me right now Joy Uber thank you so much
for joining us how is this Vlog party
gonna help us get our hands on this
listen it is time to get the community
together around this issue during Sexual
Assault Awareness Month we're so
grateful to have all of our restaurant
Partners our safe space certified
Partners we've got our Art Exhibit we've
got people coming in to do poetry and
songs and really together we can fight
this issue and believe survivors and say
we are with you absolutely and we are
how did you get this started in the
first place how'd you guys so let's
start it really yeah so it started
really with the passion uh beyond my
story my mother-in-law we lost her
literally 10 years today so it's an
important day for us her actually and my
brother-in-law and we just want to
elevate that you are you can be safe you
can be supported and we want to end
violence in our family as well as in our
community that is so beautiful I'm so
sorry to hear about your mother-in-law I
appreciate you doing this for the
community and I know that you have these
smart safe certified program one of
those places that smart Safe program is
the mothership coffee shop and you want
to hear from is from Mothership coffee
shop she will be set up right here and
for the fridge tell us a little bit
about what people can get
people can get cold brew with oat milk
and vanilla and we have different swag
available for different giveaways this
tonight lots of awesome Romero we
appreciate you joining us thank you so
much we appreciate all you do the work
you're doing in the community enjoy you
guys can find out more details on our
website newsnow.com it runs from six to
eight right here on California between
Maine and Casino Center just 10 bucks to
get in you can enjoy all of those
delicious food the coffee everything and
more of course get all of the
information you need to keep yourself
and your community safe again we got the
details for you on the website
newsnow.com for now live in Arts
District I'm Candace Charles hey newsel